the number of daily covet 19 deaths
recorded in brazil has climbed above 2
000 people for the first time over 270
000 people there have now lost their
lives to the coronavirus
a death toll surpassed only by the
united states
scientists say brazil's current wave of
infections and deaths is being fueled by
a more contagious virus variant
it started in early january in the
amazonian city of manaus
hospitals ran out of oxygen and people
died waiting for medical attention
but health experts now say complacency
has set in
and it could lead to more virus
mutations developing
and spreading dw reporter johanna
ramirez traveled to manaus to assess the
situation
lucilena da silva is back to living a
normal life
in mid january she nearly died when the
health
system in manaus collapsed she had been
infected with a new strain
of the coronavirus and needed oxygen but
the city
had run out of it
it seemed apocalyptic
the more religious people said it was a
sign of the end of the world
it was a nightmare i never thought i
would experience such a dramatic moment
it's a moment the city seems to have
forgotten
this is the main market in manaus
even though stores and businesses are
only allowed
to operate at 50 of their normal
capacity
and despite scientists warnings about
the emergence of more and more dangerous
variants
the market is always overcrowded
about 30 new strains of the coronavirus
had been detected in manaus
one of them p1 is responsible for 60
of current infections in the region
suggesting that it is more transmissible
and that number is on the rise raising
fears
of a third wave it could lead to the
emergence of even more dangerous
variants
according to the biologists who
discovered the p1 strength
people's behavior scares me because they
are seeing the situation worsen and yet
they continue to live as if things are
normal that could mean
that we will soon have a much more
serious situation
according to the studies by the vehicles
research foundation
the current vaccines are still effective
against the p1 strain
this vaccination center can administer
thousands of doses per day
but even here the authorities are unable
to implement
physical distancing
when vaccination starts there are always
a lot of people
but then the crowding goes down when
older people come for vaccination
they bring one or two relatives and
that's what
causes the crowd with more than seven
percent of its
inhabitants vaccinated the state of
amazonas
where manaus is located has administered
the most
doses to date in brazil however it is
still
far from containing the virus without
social distancing
people will continue to die from the
virus
the city has made space for 22 000 new
graves in the cemetery
it's a horrific forecast of what the new
covet variants could bring to manaus in
the near future
and journalist sam cowie joins me now
from sao paulo for more
sam as the u.s and parts of europe start
to get things more under control
brazil appears to be going in the wrong
direction with these crushing case
numbers
how did things get so out of control in
brazil
good morning claire yeah it's a really
dire situation here what we've seen
in manaus is essentially now spreading
across the country
where i am here in sao paulo which is
brazil's wealthiest and most developed
state
there are no more icu beds right now
there are thousands of people
a thousand people in fact waiting in the
queue
some people have died in the queue at
least a dozen people that we know of
have died
in the queue you know sao paulo is a
huge state 44 million people but it
really sets the tone if the richest
and most developed state in the country
is at full capacity
um essentially there are three main
problems here right now
what as the as we heard from our
colleague in the previous report
the new variant which was detected in
manaus in january
is one of the uh main cases of this what
we're seeing across the country right
now
is that the number of new cases that are
being detected it's something
like five out of eight are connected to
the new variant
it hasn't been proven necessarily the
new variant in itself is more deadly but
it is
more contagious it's twice as contagious
as the original coronavirus
and in a country like brazil if there's
more con if there's
if it's more contagious there's going to
be more people that die especially as
the hospitals
fill up the second reason is that the
vaccine uptake has been very slow across
the country
less than five percent of people have
been vaccine you know 220 million people
here in brazil
long way to go before we reach the 70
percent uh
threshold which is considered safe and
then the main reason that if you speak
to all medical professionals
is the behavior of the federal
government especially the far-right
president jaya bolsonaro who from the
beginning
has set to downplay the virus you know
when he was in florida with donald trump
it was
he said it was an invention of the media
to take down the government then it went
to being a little flu that he wouldn't
have to worry about because he used to
be an athlete then it went to being i'll
just man up we've got to get on with
things
and the thing is this kind of rhetoric
you know in brazil which is a country
it's a middle-income country lots of
people in the informal economy
lots of people you know literally
working during lunch time to put dinner
on the table
when a president says uh it won't affect
me because i used to be an
athlete you know that resonates but for
better or worse that resonates with a
lot of people
and so the loggerheads the the the the
the disconnect between the federal
government that we've seen here
and the state government here like we've
seen in sao paulo with the state
governor calling on people to really try
and you know
social distance and going to lockdown
and the president saying no we've got to
keep the economy open we've got to keep
the economy running it's just a little
flu
you know that's really caused a lot of
confusion and is one of the
main reasons uh for the high death toll
according to all the experts i've spoken
to
sam cowie in sao paulo thank you very
much for that update
you